uh apparently the intro is broke so
we're going to start from here welcome
start from here all right sorry about
that we had some technical problems
welcome back to the lobby game spots
weekly video game hangout here in san
francisco california i'm mike mchardy
your host kind of an awkward intro like
i said still don't know what john luke's
doing back there but we'll figure it out
while we just keep talking uh rob
handler you're here as well thanks for
having me we got a good show planned
today uh some zelda dlc some of them uh
what else are we talking about for honor
pray there's a preview for pray and cal
you've been playing halo wars 2. i have
this is callie palagi from our editorial
team it's me we're going to jump into
those segments in a little bit we have a
giveaway and stuff to talk about first a
few news items i want to get through a
lot of news items actually but first off
let me uh start this off quickly by
saying
uh as usual we have the youtube and
twitch chats here right next to the
camera and everything so feel free to
chime in i also got twitter questions
about these segments earlier so uh we're
happy you guys can join us
all right rob
hold this so this is a razer black widow
chroma
v2
mechanical gaming keyboard
uh we're giving away three of these so
uh in approximately like five minutes
shiva who manages our twitter account
from gamespot's twitter account we'll be
tweeting uh something about this a link
that you can click into and uh
you know
try to hopefully win a keyboard one of
these three that we have for your pc
gaming needs we should have wiped this
down like does that does my oil get on
it
that is pretty gross pretty unattractive
you made it worse i think
no richie just said it looks better now
it looks better cool
unfortunately you do not get the
attractive man holding the box he's
he's here to stay for game spot i'm
gonna take this from him cool let's get
into this uh the show today
so uh i'm gonna start with some news
items
i just almost called you bob
it happens rob you're a battlefield 1
fan sure have you played in a while
no
last time i beat all the campaign uh
war stories i did that
um
yeah what about it well as of yesterday
on ps4 xbox one pc the battlefield 1
winter update is out
class ranked caps jump from 10 to 50.
you can earn new stuff for reaching your
max class rank and also makes
battlefield 1's rent server program
there are changes to it tweaks weapon
and vehicle balances and includes a
number of fixes additionally you should
no longer get killed by a horseback
rider using a saber
from multiple meters away
oh if that was a problem dang did you
play a lot of battlefield 1 kelly no but
my dad's super into it oh yeah yeah so
was he one of those people
on the horse or getting killed by them
no he just started playing he texted me
all excited and you know like a dad way
where the text is like really
grammatically correct
and i was like i just got battlefield
one callie i'm quite enjoying it the end
of the text
um
in other news also out yesterday kind of
i don't know where was uh resident evil
7 second dlc just released on
january 24th but it is already on
rollout yeah super quick and i i'm
actually kind of glad they're doing this
they're beating the you know horizon
zero dawn nintendo switch halo wars two
for honor rush
um
i think that's their strategy i can't
imagine whales they'd be releasing so
fast but uh they've been really good so
far and john luke played band footage
volume two
and said uh he liked it a lot it's got
it so it's on ps4 as of yesterday and
then that's timed exclusive until
uh next week uh xbox one pc will release
on the 21st uh the two new missions like
the vhs tapes are 21 scenario in which
capcom says you must gamble life and
limb in a deadly game run by lucas baker
he's the brother of the family he's kind
of messed up he's the one that kind of
does the some of the escape room-ish
scenarios in the game do you guys be the
game player i have not been i have not
beaten yet i'm so scared do you know who
this is yes he's a dick i hate him yeah
and then there's a daughter scenario
which acts as a prequel to the main game
i don't want to get into spoilers but
that'll probably flesh out a couple
characters if you're not uh familiar
with you can see right here uh joey and
john luke skype he were uh
playing through this yesterday trying it
out and from like i said from what i
hear this looks like the daughter
scenario showing uh mia there
um that house looks so good
this game is believable oh oh no this is
jack's 54 no no no this okay so this is
the other thing you can get it's a
jack's 55th birthday mode and apparently
you just
in general you just have to feed him a
lot of food according to capcom so
that's there as well
so uh that's out now on ps4 uh february
21st for xbox one and pc i really like
the little egg detail on the the bar up
there little fork oh yes
like a yolk is that what that is
oh yeah a sunny-side up egg i gotcha i
think unless it's supposed to be a spoon
that's already creepy they don't have to
make them into a
goddamn clown i know
cool ugh um and in other news not as uh
exciting or
good news i guess uh disney decided to
sever ties with uh pewdiepie
for those not aware he's the famed
youtube streamer uh he
so maker studios was like owned by
disney and they had partnerships with
him
um but the wall street journal kind of
went into a lot of his videos and
published this video showing
kind of
definitely more than once
several times there were anti-semitic
symbolism like symbols and
comments that were framed as jokes in
his videos they were from his fans it
was i've never heard of the service
right but it's basically he he would pay
like five bucks to use one of these
videos the image we just had up showed
uh
it's kind of weird even without the sign
they were saying yeah you could pay five
dollars to have these guys just like
outsource videos and
they held they ended up holding up a
sign that said death to all jews in the
video and the way he framed it was that
he was trying to show how crazy it was
that he could get people to buy people
to do stuff like this
and he claims that he in no way
on his tumblr post he claims that he no
way supports hateful speech but there
are also other
times in his videos where he
there were like swastikas and whatnot
and there was this joke that he had
about hitler and
jews in relation to jesus and it kind of
sounds like he's running out of material
yeah
he like had to up the ante on how
outrageous he could be like shocked
i don't know tough about these jokes and
so disney severe ties them because they
said they didn't feel as appropriate for
the wall street journal's uh inquiries
and then um
like youtube also said they were moving
him from uh they can't google youtube
has reportedly canceled season two of
pewdiepie's reality show uh scare
pewdiepie at the same time oh man and a
youtube spokesperson said we've decided
to cancel the release of scare pewdiepie
season 2 and they're moving the
pewdiepie channel from google preferred
they did not say it was in relation to
all this but it was like yes the other
day so it was yesterday when we uh
gamespot ran the story which you see
here oscar deus and our uk office ran it
uh yeah so
he has 53 million subscribers many of
which are young men
the majority of which are and that
he
and that kind of becomes the thing where
if he's not clearly being satirical or
even if he is his words are going to
have impact and however he kind of
defends it afterwards disney and
google both were not too happy with his
stuff yeah and he's had a long history
of saying things that weren't
particularly uh
appropriate um i think it was on
waypoint um there was an article about
kind of his history of rape jokes and
and
weird sexist stuff like that too so it's
um not isolated to one incident it's
sort of like this is the last draw
because it's pretty horrible he's always
going for like irreverence but uh yeah
a lot of people myself included think he
went too far but he also if you watch
through the jokes he didn't frame them
in any way that makes them like
meaningful or actual like clearly satire
you he didn't there's no context to what
he said the and the most
ridiculous part is that like after that
like uh the sign that they held up
that's all jews
my god he just cuts to his reaction
and he's like appalled yeah right but
he's editing his own videos right yeah
you can't pull that like it's you gotta
roll as someone like that like yeah it's
carefully edited that was actually part
of the waypoint piece i just mentioned
is the um the fact that like if there's
a difference between offhand saying
something like if you're a streamer or
something you're just kind of doing like
two hours straight and but and carefully
editing
what you're putting up and like seeing
it beforehand and knowing that
maybe you're crossing a line um also i i
get really irritated with satire that
with satire that is um
not properly done because like
everyone's like oh i said you know
a slur and i'm so funny and it's not
you're not critiquing anything and that
doesn't make his satire it's tough to do
and when you
[ __ ] it up it just comes off like in
this case being stupid yeah and he has
impact on 53 million people he could go
to a different video streaming service
if youtube didn't work out and he would
that service would blow up just because
of him uh but yeah so disney summer ties
google removed him from google preferred
and canceled pewdiepie season two i'm
sure he'll be just fine hopefully he
just
learns
what not to say in the future
uh we'll see yeah and then on our last
newsreel which is also a good segue into
our first segment
we are gonna go with
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
announced an expansion pass for twenty
dollars um starting
i believe you can like pay for it now if
you pre-order it but
if that
so that i want to talk about because
people are like kind of outraged about
this um
i want to talk about why zelda is
getting that kind of scrutiny when
we've kind of come to grips with the
fact that every other franchise can do
this um so just to run through quick
what it'll include
uh we
it'll be a 20 expansion pass for the
year there will be an update in like
right at launch on march 3rd when the
switch and breath of the wild release
one in the summer and then one during
the holiday uh you have here the
expansion pass that releases at launch
will be three new treasure chests
containing useful items found in the
great plateau area of the open world the
exclusive england clothing is this is
the part i have a problem with uh it's a
t-shirt that link can wear that just
promotes the nintendo switch we can get
back to that because that's that's the
only problem i have with this uh dlc
pack one adds new cave of trials
challenge if you played twilight
princess um
it probably sounds familiar to you it's
kind of a boss enemy run or at least it
wasn't toilet princess i'm not sure how
it's going to manifest in breath of the
wild there's a new hard mode so this
entire kind of mode being withheld mate
kind of like a resident evil 7's dlc
additional map feature i don't know if
that's an area or
who knows uh
and then we have the uh holiday new
original story a new dungeon and
additional challenges
so
uh someone on twitter actually asked the
question that i wanted to uh roll with
it was
rayquaza kingdom said why is dlc why is
dlc okay with any non-nintendo game but
zelda gets it and it's a travesty
so that's a good question because you
know zelda's one of those franchises we
kind of hold up as being like there's a
sanctity to it that you can't touch and
until like hyrule warriors came around
and they started branching it off into
different
kind of formats but
i don't necessarily have a complete
problem with this nintendo's always kind
of been in its own bubble and i think
they're opening up to
other modern game trends but it just
disappoints me that this is the first
one we hear about instead of like
knowing exactly how online capabilities
are gonna work with a nintendo switch
launch but i also don't like the fact
that link can have a nintendo switch
shirt on i don't think that's a cool i
mean it's gimmicky and it's like uh if
you play the wii u version of breath of
the wild which we all did at e3
he's got that tablet which is clearly
like the gamepad from the wii u it's
just nintendo's like doesn't always know
how to break the fourth wall and that
worries me that
they're so behind on these dlc expansion
pass trends that they're gonna [ __ ] it
up that it's such a small thing this
shirt that link can wear but it makes me
think that they don't exactly know what
they're doing the rest of stuff i i'm
fine with because if i love breath of
wild which it looks like i will i have
no idea i haven't played more two hours
with it but i've been watching streams
and everything i have no problem with
paying more money for more of the game
if i really like it but this leads me to
believe that they don't necessarily have
it
in their grasp what they want to do with
it
yeah i mean i i think i really like your
point about um like is this really the
first trend like the first modern trend
they're going to approach because
nintendo is notoriously slow on the
uptake with those kinds of things um i
mean that's probably too harsh i think
nintendo kind of just goes its own way
um i don't really see a problem with
deals it doesn't bother me at all i
don't know why that's something to get
actually angry about there's other
things i'd get a lot angrier about um i
think the shirt is the weirdest thing
for sure uh just because it it's almost
like they were like oh you know people
really like the shirts and splatoon that
you can get remember when you had
pizza hut or transformers or whatever it
was that was cool and it's like no
totally different thing extremely
different right especially when zelda is
i mean always has been a very immersive
game i don't want to be reminded of is
like what i'm holding
no because long ago before the hylian
wars the gorons passed down this
nintendo switcher which came and
banished the king again and of course
it's [ __ ] canon
yeah i mean you're not gonna wear that
no one's gonna wear that i don't know
who would but the one that actually like
hit me was that hard mode right like
what
at what point is that
something that you know was i mean who
knows what hard mode exactly is you know
is it maybe more like a survival mode
type thing which you know would make i
guess more sense but
um
that just you know at its at its broader
like
core it just sounds like it sounds like
something that should be in the game
already well here's the thing because
those that as well as the new dungeon
are not unprecedented because in uh
links awakening when you when it came on
the game bar color game boy color they
added a dungeon to entice people like
this is a different game it's on game
boy color it's not showing game boy you
can buy it go through this dungeon
there's a few other additional features
uh also
yes uh link between worlds had the hero
mode but like you said uh that launched
with the game you could play it it was
harder yeah like in like ocean of time
3d in the master quest right it was that
was released on the gamecube version
whereas link between worlds had it at
launch so
this isn't just a nintendo question this
is a question of how often do developers
release games when they're purposely
withholding things which a game this
massive and from the development cycle
it seems like it's been through i
imagine these things are already ready
to go they're just holding it and i
we're gonna see like
you know super mario odyssey dlc
expansion pass i think the problem i
have with it again is that
or at least the worry i have i don't
have like immediate uh massive problem
with it i do agree with uh rayquaza
kingdom on twitter that we kind of
do tend to give nintendo [ __ ] for things
it's always nintendo's like that sacred
developer that sacred of the big three
uh companies that we kind of
seem to hold to a higher standard even
though maybe not a higher standard we
kind of think they're
they're in their own bubble so it seems
like they're opening up to dlc expansion
passes with the switch
but you know like hopefully they focus
on the right trends in the future and
not just expansion passes
yeah
yeah like a lot of people are hoping to
see a version of trophies and we still
have no idea what like how the online
capabilities will work with the switch
we don't know a lot about the console
but we know breath of the wild will have
an expansion pass for 20 or like if
splatoon 2 will have voice chat which
would be cool
thanks nintendo
or like i mean
so many people have pre-ordered this
game right
i and what was like the top pre-orders
like 120 bucks right i think so how
frustrated would you be if like they are
oh if you got like the master edition
you got that and then they
are attacking on more stuff like i mean
i guess
ultimately i mean that's what i will
plan to do is like just not
get it and play the game first and
that's what most people should do yeah i
mean you don't have to get it yeah
obviously yeah yeah leroy jenkins on
youtube leroy jenkins on youtube chat
made a good point uh mario kart 8 did
have a season pass from i believe on the
wii u which it was kind of a
an anomaly i think maybe maybe because
it's zelda
that it's the people are mad yeah maybe
that people are please don't touch zelda
but i don't know i think it was
inevitable and i get i get
maybe because
like i said nintendo's been kind of
isolated from these trends lately that
they weren't used to it like if ea had
expansion passes like okay that makes
sense if they didn't have it would be
weird but the fact that nintendo has one
for zelda maybe feels weird but i guess
that's we're in 2017 now well yeah i
mean yeah i mean that is a good point
that they just they're not new to this
they did the uh dlc for animal crossing
new leaf and the mario kart one that
leroy jenkins brought up um and i am
even re-releasing mario kart 8 with
updated content on the switch is
something they're doing so it's
maybe people are mad because they love
zelda so much i don't know if it's a
nostalgia thing for nintendo that's why
people get so mad i don't i don't know
yeah i was not that angry no yeah bad
stuff
i mean if they want to do those gimmicky
switch t-shirts or stone tablets or
whatever it is then
go for it i won't touch those but i'd
rather just get the metal armor speaking
of which i showed rob this gift this
morning i don't know if you're around no
so we're just talking about how
incredibly like
simulation driven this game is uh in
terms of like the wildlife animations
they're showing uh during there's a lot
of uh streams in
japan recently and
uh nick doof on twitter was going
through and making gifts out of a lot of
the gameplay and apparently as you know
it's way more rpg driven in this game
you can have like uh different kinds of
armor uh you know food when he cooks he
hums and it's really cute
he
also if you're wearing a metal
like a suit of armor in a storm
apparently i wish i had the gift ready i
didn't pull it up for you i did see that
gift where you get destroyed get struck
by lightning and when i say struck by
lightning i mean he gets obliterated
because he's a huge suit of armor and
all of a sudden you see these sparks for
about five seconds in which
time period you're supposed to be like
[ __ ] let me put on the tunic or even get
naked so i don't get destroyed by
lightning and then the ground around him
just gets scorched he explodes falls
over it is like a mini nuke yeah it's
hilarious insane uh yeah the warnings it
gives that's it's so great it was great
um yes and then also josh richards on
twitter kind of asked the same question
how do you feel the shady business the
shady business of pre-release pay dlc
will affect nintendo games going forward
i think we're going to see a lot more of
it on the switch generation especially
if zelda is the precursor to all of it
or i guess mario kart 8 but now it's
zelda on the switch so we'll see more of
it for sure it looks like he has a big
goron sword there or just a big sword i
can't wait for this game i really can't
you know on march 3rd i'm so pumped
yeah awesome so
yeah those are our thoughts on
nintendo's expansion pass dlc uh for
people watching thank you for joining
the chat and on twitter uh we have a
good rest of the show coming up but
keep sending me your thoughts sending it
to cali plaguey mike maherty rob hanley
on twitter and we'll uh hopefully get
back to you
cool
um cool now on to more uh
game stuff
rob you saw prey recently
yeah
i can't wait i did i did sorry it's
gonna give another game yeah i thought
that was gonna happen a little bit later
but yeah uh pray man um sorry
yeah uh
scott butterworth and i we saw the first
hour
of what is led to believe as uh the
the full game um
which was
kind of frustrating
or i would say unfortunate because the
first half hour of the game is kind of
like just like half hour of the game
yeah story beat and then it wasn't until
about halfway that through that hour was
when you actually got this kind of
experiment right so this is very much
like a dishonored
bioshock all these different like
like real
uh
clear but tasteful i would say
inspirations
um
but i had a pretty good time with it
it's it was uh kind of endearing in a
way where uh i wanted to continue to
play that unfortunately we didn't see
any of like um
if you've seen any of the gameplay
trailers uh the powers you get to
eventually kind of uh take from these
creatures called typhons mm-hmm and uh
the aliens in the game those are the
aliens in the game uh that uh board this
science lab space station and
tear it apart
um but yeah you can you know the
gameplay trailer is like we're so cool
you just turn into a cup
and then use kinetic energy to launch
yourself over a wall but um yeah we
didn't see any of that so it was very
just like kind of uh immediate core uh
abilities you kind of have yeah and
it i want to talk about like you touched
on it how it's influenced by bioshock
then you go even back and farther
bioshock was influenced by you know
system shock 2 which ken levine it was
his first big game he worked on um prey
is being made by arcane studios which
dishonored fame dishonored 2 fame with
harvey smith and
ralph cole antonio the latter of which
is the one heading up prey and obviously
this is the reboot they had there was
that whole controversy when pete hines
from bethesda said
uh something about no arcane's not
doesn't have rights to pray to but then
it turned out it was kind of just uh
you know facetious because they had the
reboot they were working on anyway they
have prey the reboot now and it looks
great and it looks like bioshock and it
looks like system shock it goes back to
the looking glass days if you're
familiar with like a system shock or
ultimate underworld back in the 90s this
first person immersive uh
choice consequence driven sim uh i guess
they describe it as which is like
dishonored you know you have all these
abilities you have these different ways
that these levels can unfold um there's
that zero four five one code that's the
number that's in all these games uh from
ray bradley oh really yeah fahrenheit
451. so bioshock it unlocks a door
uh thief it unlocks a chest i believe
thief made by uh looking glass as well
um an ion storm who did deus ex harvey
smith worked on it it's in there as well
and it's in dishonored two it's just
very often a code that opens a safe or
anything it's just in reference to ray
bradbury's fahrenheit 451
uh
the temperature at which books burn in
that book
in that story but it's that's a really
cool easter egg in all these games and
that's actually like
what i want to talk about all the games
i just mentioned kind of uh
how they're influencing prey and even
like you go back to dishonored two but
prey despite the fact that it's by
arcane it looks very different right
obviously the sci-fi elements the you
know the more horror elements than
dishonored but
in terms of the choice and
consequence-driven
gameplay station whereas dishonor was
these discrete levels it was also
different structurally but i'm i really
want to like talk about because i know
kelly you're a really big shooter fan as
well i am and i'm assuming you played
bioshock and did you ever get the chance
to try out like system shock or anything
back in the day or like no i'm a baby
yeah i i didn't play until recently um i
didn't beat it it's pretty tough it's
yeah it's accessible anymore but they're
doing the remake up in uh portland i
believe i forget the name of the
developer i'll look it up
uh and yeah we
are looking at this right now so
i did a video today and i uh i'm really
happy with it because uh for one i
haven't done a video feature in a while
and this was really fun to look at so
uh i believe this is tamora and lucy's
video and i kind of did a touch on
basically just these guys right here
called mimics
and
they are like it's kind of
unfortunately segway they're really
unique like i've never really
seen an enemy that
essentially makes you approach an open
room and go okay right here this is
great like okay okay so watch this right
there yeah yeah three of them flower pot
that's really good
yeah a pot a uh a flower and a radio so
that happens a couple times where you
approach a room and they they all kind
of like cooperate and
uh well wait like one time i killed one
of them and then like all right cool the
room is now like cleared mm-hmm and
later on they like were in a corner the
whole time three of them just like
waiting and then they attacked and like
really messed me up uh so it's it's this
really unique idea of like
like what's the purpose of actually like
you know knocking over a object on the
table in any other game right right here
it's like there's a purpose because
you're trying to see which one of them
is an actual like alien yeah scott
butterworth editor who went with you to
the preview event he was saying that it
kind of plays with your expectations of
physics in games or even just the
environment right you kind of take it
for granted that these physics objects
can like just roll around but now you're
actually paying attention because it
could be a threat which is awesome right
like you look at the room one way the
first time you enter it so it like it's
a level design that's like
two for one fits two different purposes
yeah it's the second time you look at
once you think you've cleared the room
then you're like okay it's such a great
way to fit into the horror of the game
yeah
like always uneasy it's exactly that and
uh then there's also the side uh
component of sometimes these mimics are
a little obvious when like you go in a
room and like you eventually start
learning like how to like you know
investigate so you'll see like a pair of
shoes
and then there's an extra shoe
the last three shoes
most people have two feet and sure
enough he's one of those guys but it's
like they're like they panic because
like though sometimes if they're by
themselves they'll scatter uh
and uh try to basically like quickly
it's like okay what's in the room uh a
shoe
yeah for those in the end right for
those youtube chat really quick uh anvil
one gaming ryan schubert here at kevin's
not just posted rob's feature video uh
the youtube link so uh check that out
check that out after the show copy that
paste into your uh browser now
not now it's a really it's a good
feature but i'd rather you watch
us talk right now yeah but so anyways
touching back you know stay here so you
know these guys are original but yeah
back to like uh you know the
inspirations uh i would say what for me
the first one was in light of like
bioshock it was
being underwater right and seeing this
place crumble one of the first things
this game does prey is you kind of first
get to a big open area and then
you know part of the
space station just explodes you see all
this stuff just eject into
you know the death of space and right
away you're kind of thinking about that
right and so it's that claustrophobic
tendency as well that you kind of
are always thinking about in that game
it's it's very similar to bioshock in
that way yeah it seems like the next the
logical evolution of you know rapture
underwater colombia from bioshock infant
in the sky uh and then you go back to
system shock which is also on the space
station uh it's these these games really
love taking these isolated communities
and showing how like i don't know to be
a pessimist humans are always going to
[ __ ] it up right rapture was uh it's a
lot of a lot of dystopian and sci-fi
stuff is about humans [ __ ] stuff up
yeah and i was watching i was playing
the bioshock collection recently on ps4
and i was watching the developer
commentary from back in the day when
jeff keeley interviewed i believe it was
nate robinson and ken levine for these
commentaries and they were saying
rapture in large part aside from the
they actually
thought of doing an underwater city
before they decided to make it like this
dystopian iron randy and kind of like
galt gulch if you've read atlas shrugged
this isolated community of the brightest
minds in the world and how they just
devolved into this dystopia but they
actually did rapture at first because
they wanted you to feel like you were
actually confined in this world that
they use the metaphor i think they're in
new york when they were doing the
interview so they're saying we didn't
want you to look over and see new jersey
and feel weird that you couldn't go
there we want you to look out into the
water
and know you're trapped and just
accept what you're seeing which this
space station seems like the next uh
logical evolution that which is pretty
cool uh in my mind like tacoma is
releasing by the fulbright company in uh
sometime this year they haven't
announced the release date yet but
it there's that vein of games that does
that really well even dishonored if you
want to talk about like well-designed
worlds
you know you have at eve which kind of
like fuels your plasmids in bioshock and
then you have adam which is what they
pull from the slugs on the sea floor
which powers the eve i might be
butchering that a little bit but then
you have there's always this like very
uh well-formed world in these games and
it's integral to how the mechanics work
right it's whale oil it's a whaling
community in
uh dishonored but also your powers come
from the outsider i believe his name is
who gives you the supernatural powers
like blink and far reach and everything
and i think these games are kind of back
in the 90s they were really ahead of
their time but i think i'm really
excited because you know dishonored
dishonored 2 and from what it looks like
prey are kind of bringing that back
right and i'm really excited for to see
how prey will unfold in this open world
mm-hmm not in the sense of like breath
of the wild or horizon but this open
mission with on like within the space
station that you're exploring right
rather than discrete like distinct
yeah i just wanted to add those nine
missions and uh it's i'm looking forward
to seeing how it unfolds um yeah i guess
in this case they would be neural mods
that you find in the game
oh it sucks you have to it does yeah i
suck i was thinking about the other day
it was like if he's doing this how many
dozens of times like your eye
essentially it's like a looking glass
space two kind of thing got three like
long ass needles just like okay
imagine just taking like a telescope i
can open doors
i can turn into a cup now
it looks unsettling it i don't love
stuff to do with my eyes i value them no
and they i don't like poking myself yeah
a little stabbing well if i could change
into a [ __ ]
[Music]
microphone i would stab myself in the
eye in an instant i feel like the better
would be the better way would be your
nose right yeah that but if you
butchered that you could actually kill
yourself
because you would just hit your brain
apex penguins what you're doing right
you're still going who knows
uh apex penguin just said the outsider
of dishonored started out as the penguin
in gotham and when batman finally killed
him he pledges eternal soul to darkness
so there's your lore for dishonored uh
you learned something new
every day that's mine for the day um
now you're done you're done learning for
the rest of the day turning my brain off
for all intents and purposes
i'm really really excited for prey i was
just tweeting the other day about how it
might be my most anticipated game this
year despite the fact that breath of the
wild is on the horizon
and horizons on the horizon but i
i love zelda
and it looks like it'll be a fantastic
game but right now i'm excited for prey
may 5th i believe it releases yeah i
really love everything arcane does even
like going back to arc's fatalist days
they're kind of breakout hit i mean
dishonored was kind of their breakout in
2012 but ark's fatalis earlier
six years before that or something was
kind of they're showing their stuff
because they worked on uh bioshock 2 a
little bit as well i just i love a good
sci-fi i really hope that the sci-fi
setup continues like holds up throughout
the game like i'm
super excited to see how that goes and
how it uh
meshes with the gameplay and the kind of
different kind of mission that you're
going on as opposed to like we mentioned
dishonored definitely i'm really looking
forward to it even like seeing maybe
some dead space influences outside of
the
eyeball stabbing yeah some of the later
horror elements i believe uh you know
the creatures i guess you could count on
them progressively getting more intense
and there's one called
nightmare yes and this sounds awesome
you've seen the gameplay of it it's just
giant like gorilla but it can like
still manage like um creep under doors
but essentially as you um eventually get
powers
and use the powers like that are from
the aliens uh that dude like senses it
yeah so it's that like he hunts you like
you like the nemesis if you played
resume through exactly it's like a
procedural thing from what i've on from
what i understand yeah and also uh one
of my favorite pieces of trivia about
bioshock 2 is that initially jordan
thomas who led production
led development and uh people like steve
gainer at the fulbright company and
carlos amona who are at the fullback
company now who worked on bioshock 2.
the initial intent with the big sisters
which if you remember if you play
bioshock 2 which is one of the most
underrated games of all time i will
stick by that
the big sisters were not gonna be
multiple big sisters there's gonna be
one that hunted you the whole time
procedurally and that sounded awesome
but
they ditched that because they didn't
think people would be like okay with
that in a bioshock sequel because the
bioshock fans who came into bioshock to
be like this [ __ ] hard and terrifying
i don't want to deal with this right
they ended up just making like story
beats sounds like they're going for that
with a nightmare later on in prey though
which sounds awesome that's awesome
which will just further increase the
terror you feel when that item that
ladder in our studio could be a mimic or
whatever or when you oh
it's turned into rats and scattered no
every time you walk in a room you see a
mimic like become a trash can really
quick it's just like a little kid who's
like i close my eyes they won't see me
it's really funny oh would it be great
to be like a cop right
and then that guy comes in the room
nope yes uh yeah so i'm really excited
for prey and uh i'm excited to see how
bioshock system shock
deus ex kind of you know and arcane's
other work on dishonored kind of
transfers over to it so let us know your
thoughts kelly plague on twitter rob
handler on twitter mike mchardy on
twitter uh
i think we're all pretty excited for
this game so let us know what you think
uh yeah so the rest of the show we're
getting into halo wars 2 which kelly's
been playing we're going to that next
we're also going to need a for honor rob
and i spent some time with the campaign
multiplayer we're gonna talk about that
our thoughts on that um the review will
be up some point this week uh we've been
playing it matt spinelli's been playing
for a couple days but
let's get into halo wars 2. so all three
of us are big halo fans shooter fans in
general
um
been working rob you and i been working
together for like a year and a half and
we probably talk about halo maybe once a
week sure some respect yeah uh and then
kelly i know you like a lot of shooters
and i love halo so much yes okay so
you're in good company yes um
you've been playing halo words too right
we can't completely talk about
everything we can't talk too much about
story um the
review will be up tomorrow so look out
for that on gamespot.com a cool website
that you may have heard of before um but
i do want to touch on um some of the
gameplay stuff for halo fans i see a lot
of
um not parallels but kind of where it
takes its inspiration from different
halo missions yeah um
so like there's just stuff that feels
like the warthog run you know and like
um
i'm i've been enjoying that
a lot um the halo nods and being like oh
yeah this is like so badass like i get
those flashbacks when i first played
combat evolves and i was like this is
the best game
um and then the rts elements uh almost
take a back seat for me
uh which is
i guess it depends what you're looking
for but
i was able to just kind of
breeze through a lot of things just like
highlighting all of my units and being
like all right go over there do this
yeah speaking as someone who loves halo
and rts i played about half of the
campaign of halo wars 2 and i completely
agree with you that
it takes a lot of nods from not just
like halo campaign but like shooters and
i think
you know the question is always is this
an rts game for halo fans or a halo game
for rts fans and i think it's the former
it is absolutely the former rts game for
halo fans because
there are a lot of things even the new
uh multiplayer modes like blitz and
domination
are very much kind of these things
you're used to in shooters they're these
zone control very fast paced jump
jump-in jump out modes that rts fans
might not traditionally be used to they
work well in the rts structure and kind
of change up how you play yeah but they
are very accessible for someone i could
immediately look at domination be like
oh i've played a lot of halo 3 in my
time i kind of get how this works i'm
going to send these units to here
capture it exactly defend it a little
bit move to the next one get resources
um
but like you said the warthog run from
the end of halo 1 and 3 is like the
first mission in this game it's not
really a spoiler it's just it's showing
you how to move around units but it's
also like i i love that it functions as
a tutorial essentially if you if i was
trying to imagine it like in an rts yeah
you have a single ward hog okay if you
skip the tutorial which don't because
you get an achievement for it if you
care about that um
i i do um
yeah it's it's just like here's how you
move around the map but it's it reminded
me so much of the the warthog run and
yeah you're just controlling a single
warthog through an environment um and
just following kind of waypoints
um the the one thing like a big gripe i
have is you can't zoom out very far and
i just yeah i always felt like i
couldn't get a good enough view of the
battlefield especially later on
um
but you know the other perspective
almost feels more like an isometric game
rather than a i mean it is
isometric in a lot of spots it feels
more like a dungeon crawler sometimes
when you're looking at it than an rts
that you could zoom out with yeah and
like zooming in i never zoomed in i
stayed almost at it's funny that he's
zooming in on this
um i almost always was fully zoomed out
yeah playing i just didn't need to be
zoomed in unless you wanted to like see
something up close i love grunts so i
saw grunt once and i was like oh that's
my my best friend their garbled stuff so
that right there looked like a uh
oh god the name of the move in halo is
um crown pound yes yeah there are like
the spartans again the spartans the
heroes
a lot of rts have these abilities but
spartans can kind of do stuff like that
you know they have the spartan laser
obviously you'll recognize the weapons
if you played a lot of halo they're also
the mission structure
feels very influenced by like a halo
campaign like from the time i played
there's a boss fight it in an rts
absolutely i mean we shouldn't get too
too into it but um
it's absolutely like if like a halo game
will go from like guns blazing to you
got to be super careful and watch
yourself um
and this felt a lot like that that's so
funny you know hearing you talk about it
uh
it's like okay yeah i mean i could see
halo influences but this map is totally
uh combat evolved the second map when
you land um halo yeah the first one
that's totally it where you get to kind
of explore it there's there are other
missions that just even the name it's
taken from the first halo um
like a beach head
and then you kind of rush up it again i
don't want to spoil anything but yeah
there's skulls you can get skulls yeah
if you do secondary object do you get
skulls this is very much
the question i wanted to ask um because
we can set up the premise right or the
story pretty quickly no we can't we
can't there's like a thing at the very
beginning that
like
yeah we can't really talk about that the
premise there is part of the premise is
that um
uh there is a rogue brute faction called
the banished um and that's who you're up
against here
about when this takes place the covenant
yes after five yeah so it's it's a
28 years after halo wars 1 i believe
28 or 20 yeah 28. um so we we can know
that yes but um
this is this is where it gets yeah
tricky because i don't explain anything
but it is even the story itself kind of
bookends things that happen in the halo
story line and i think
like i said is halo wars 2 essential for
a halo fan and
essential's a strong word but
i think if you are a halo fan and you
have some passing interest in rts and
flashing out the story i think it's
worth your time um
it is a bareboned rts i don't like
starcraft fans or warcraft 3 fans might
not
love this uh but it does flesh out the
story in a great way and i think it
actually like i said is accessible if
you just have played the halo shooters
for like rob i could see you getting
into this yeah i don't think you play
many rts games right it's super
accessible i will say i do like rts's i
mean i like like red alert too yeah
that's one of my favorite games ever
you've starcraft warcraft 2 like
definitely into it um yeah i honestly
was not inclined to play this but just
i guess the nostalgia factor would maybe
pull me in more than i thought when you
were talking about i was like okay yeah
you know i wanna
you wanna enjoy the game the other day
right and
but there's still something about halo
that can still
lure me in there's always gonna be
something at halo even the cinematics uh
which i won't say the subject of
them but um even them i'm like watching
them and being like i just [ __ ] love
halo so much it's definitely a lot of
fan service uh blur studios i believe
did the cutscenes right they did the
halo 2 uh anniversary cutscenes
yes probably the most gorgeous cutscenes
ever outside of like blizzard games
these are the best looking cutscenes
ever look great yeah and so i was just
it felt like very um
directed at me as a halo fan in general
um and i think you know it's a very
simple interface for an rts it's kind of
like a two button attack system um same
with the first one um so in that sense
it's very accessible i did find myself
um
like
trying to mash x which is like the
attack but just because i was so used to
having like i'm like oh attack shoot now
and that's obviously not how it works
and so i had to untrain my brain
out of that have you been using control
groups at all with like i think you can
map them to d-pad so you can just group
like the hellbringers together and then
the marines together in a different
group yeah i wish it were more specific
like i wish i could uh assign like a
custom group like oh i'm going to have
you know two warthogs that's some hell
bringers
stuff that's a bummer yeah yeah like a
cyclops and um
it's been working on pc i've played uh
on pc yeah i haven't been playing on
xbox just to clarify it does work well
on pc you can have like a warthog a
hellbringer a spartan but yeah on
controllers right you have to double tap
a unit and then map like every marine on
screen to one group or something yeah
it's it's complex i mean honestly i
haven't really had to bother with that
much it's not i'm playing on uh normal
for the purposes of the review so
when i play it through on a higher
difficulty that's probably not going to
be the case but for
you know just for anyone who's playing
on the average difficulty i don't think
that's going to be even really necessary
um i was
basically like just paint highlighting
units and sending them to where i needed
them and it was
almost there were times where i i
finished a mission like i won the
mission i was like oh
it's over already okay i did it oops so
that was my impression from playing
about half the campaign on pc is that
when i actually tried to be really
tactical and rts minded and have the
hellbringers you know hit this garrison
the spartan jerome and the marines hit
this building while my warthog shoot at
this it didn't feel like that was
completely necessary like it might be
like
you know dividing up attacks attack
groups when you're going for base and
you know like red alert or starcraft or
warcraft it felt like i was trying to do
too much for an rts that didn't want me
to think that much and
that comes into your um your comment
about being accessible it feels like if
i invade a base with an army yeah it
helps to kind of divide up what they're
doing but after a while just kind of
devolves into everybody shoot this thing
and then all of you shoot this thing and
then once that's done everybody shoot at
this thing throw grenades yeah i there
were there were some instances where
that's not the case but yeah if the if
there's more
like i'm gonna as soon as we're done
here i'm gonna go play more so uh if
there's more customization that would be
cool i haven't even had to bother
looking for it yet
so in general what's your take if you're
a halo fan should you play this i mean
i'm sure people will go on youtube and
just watch all the cutscenes to get the
story
but
yeah i mean yeah if you like really
don't want to play an rts then yeah sure
read the plot synopsis i guess but like
i can't force you to play it but i would
say it's definitely
an rts for halo fans like you said not
a
halo game for our team rts fans um but
if you would like more detailed
information you can check out my review
tomorrow yes game spot also has a few
feature videos up nick margarita did
some stuff on halo wars 2. he went up to
343 studios recently did a couple
interviews put up a few feature videos
oh speaking of nick margarita he wants
to talk about us to talk about the blitz
mode you want to i mean we can i we're
kind of running you know we're going to
talk about blitz mode um so blitz
correct me if i'm wrong is the card the
deck building mode so you can uh in
campaign if you rank up
maybe it carries over into skirmish but
you have these decks these cards kind of
like any deck building game and you get
to pick
uh start forming your deck and bring it
into blitz mode and you play these decks
at the same time so someone like nick
margarita was saying he'll bring a bunch
of cheaper cards like uh odst would be
80 marines would be 60 or something you
bring a bunch of those and then two
really strong cards like a mac blast or
a scorpion tank and then bring those in
it kind of just affects what you are
bringing into the fight yeah it's like
an rts twist on blitz which i think is
an interesting concept
for sure
yeah so that's that's pretty cool and
that you can rank up and unlock new
cards in campaign
kind of a cross cross play thing between
campaign and multiplayer but yeah like i
said it's they're kind of bringing a few
different genres now they have deck
building in this i think that what you
will i like the bridging between
campaign and multiplayer because that's
something that some games just drop
completely so i always appreciate an
effort put there i will say yeah um but
you know cool yeah awesome so uh yeah
kelly your review will be up
soon very soon this week i gotta go
right
yeah we'll let you get back to that for
the show uh that'll be up and then like
i said we have video features up on
gamespot you can go check those out and
uh yeah stay tuned to game spot for the
rest of the week for more halo wars 2
coverage and for the review and to see
our final thoughts
i like it i'm having fun with it so far
i think rob i think you should try it
out maybe as a halo fan cool yeah
maybe i'll check it out i just might
last segment
gonna get into for honor
which
judging by
traffic for for honor stories on
gamespot for the past two years gamespot
audience really likes for honor at least
is excited about it or cares a lot about
it uh we've been playing it rob and i uh
like i said kelly's been busy with halo
awards too have you played a 400 at all
i have not and my first question for you
is i don't care about it at all i have
not been interested it's not a question
she should
she's not there yet should i be
shut up mike
sorry should i be um
should i be more interested than i am
like should i have this on my radar
from what you've played
i'm more interested than i initially was
if that answered your question um yeah
you were kind of every time i would
mention it even did you play bear you'd
like no i'm not interested
literally i've heard that come out of
your mouth uh well i played the closed
alpha back in the day okay um and it did
interest me but i think now that i think
we kind of want to focus a little more
on the story mode during this segment
but obviously we could talk about the
whole game i think just because story
mode is the new thing no one's touched
yet
well
game release yesterday so i guess people
have touched it now but
it was one of those games where it was
much deeper than i initially thought
like really deep uh
in the sense that there are a lot of
things that tutorials won't even tell
you or the game might not tell you
initially that you you know there's
emerging stuff that comes up as you play
more okay um
if you're looking for just a good story
don't don't don't i is it is it really
bad because i wouldn't i wouldn't expect
a great story from a game that's
multiplayer focused it's serviceable
like
for the story mode uh purposes so the
story mode function is just kind of like
a uh training gown for a moment it
really is yeah and it will show you
different you know you could follow the
path of uh this warden for the knights
um
then follow the path of a samurai with
the samurai and then a viking and it
becomes this each you got to you learn
new moves in each mission and then it
also frames it with this bare-bones
story which rob you have you can't
really stand can you yeah it was just
kind of i don't
i just wasn't into it yeah i'm not
trying to like dock the game for not
having a good story because i didn't
expect it all and it's a multiplayer
focused game so yeah but i don't but
it's it's almost to the point where it's
like
painfully cheesy at some point yeah
that's the difference is it's like
i don't it doesn't have to have a good
story but if the story is so painful
that i don't want to get through it
that's another story that will fall it's
not another story you know what i mean
that bad but it is it's i it's a hard
time exploring it's very it's very
like
it's testosterone driven
it's boring for me
right here this scene right here he says
uh he was expecting an army they sent me
oh my gosh
yeah no that's the
man
doing man things just guys bad dudes um
just a couple of guys
for me it actually kind of just like
takes
it sounds like minor but what kind of
takes me out of it is the fact that only
once so far i've played like the first
three
four chapters of the um uh crusade
what's this a warden excuse me
you don't see anyone's face you see one
you see the main one dude
and it's just it just comes off as just
a guy in a vo booth that's what i keep
hearing maybe that's because like i i
really enjoy voice acting for the most
part i'd like to hear good voice acting
and so it's just two guys in helmets i
just feel like i'm not
i just feel like i'm looking at a
talking helmet sure and that gets tiring
for me where i keep seeing two guys
who aren't looking at each other
they're just looking away from it's just
like it
it nags cool dudes who can't look each
other in the eye well like you said the
a big problem is not with not seeing
faces and not having some kind of facial
emo they do these emphatic dumb gestures
right time because
how else are you going to
you know visualize someone talking or
someone uh expressing concern or emotion
so you have these uh
exaggerated arm motions like
i'm going over here yeah
uh interesting but i'm waving my arms
around it
uh wait can we cut back to rob so we can
do it one more time sorry
come on let's go
follow me
or it's like i'm right here
it just gets
annoying for me and i get tired of that
yeah and like we said i don't think any
of us were expecting a great story but
in terms of the structure of the
campaign how it functions within the
game to prep you for multiplayer i think
it's serviceable uh it gets repetitive
when you're just plowing through the um
the i don't know if you want to call
like creeps i guess if you're going to
use a moba term uh plowing through them
but then obviously the games that's best
when you're fighting another hero unit
which you have to block and parry and
use specific attacks against
and that's where the multiplayer comes
in because those characters are other
players um and it does a good job
prepping you i would actually recommend
if you're playing for the first time the
campaign serves the story mode i don't
even know if they call it a campaign but
you get what i'm saying it does a good
job of showing you the ropes for sure
rather than just a bare bone tutorial
and there's like high production value
this game looks really good yeah it
seriously does and it's cool like going
through i guess again it's not a
riveting it's got eyes
it's not a riveting story it's just
again it facilitates everything so the
campaign i would recommend jumping into
it first but i want to talk about the
multiplayer
this game is
far deeper than i
i think we all were thinking it would be
but it's definitely far deeper than we
all initially thought or a lot of us
it's
it's like a 3d fighting game mixed with
these moba aspects which i think are
implemented really well
it can be intimidating to go up against
people because you have these three
block directions you have these three
attack directions but you also have a
heavy attack a light attack you have
these shield bashes like body slams you
have these drop attacks it's
it's crazy like they actually managed to
make this multiplayer melee game
with kind of modern multiplayer tenets
like control zones and whatnot and moba
like creeps and it works well i like it
how's the balancing for you so far
um
in terms of like the character balance
yeah it
i think it is in the sense that you know
you're going up against uh [ __ ] i forgot
what this viking he's fighting right now
is called so i believe this is a warden
that they're playing as the knights
warden but you have to read each
character differently and there are
telegraphs to certain moves each each
fight against another player feels like
a boss fight almost this duel because
you can dodge but you can also block but
you have to block in the right direction
so
this
uh i don't know there's like a valkyrie
character i mean they might be the ones
with a spear they'll be harder to read
and but they're faster and do less
damage but they'll be harder to read
than a warden might with this two-handed
sword oh this isn't a warden this is a
samurai sorry
but you can see which side they're
holding the sword down so you see where
they're gonna attack from you can kind
of parry it but yeah it feels really
balanced in terms of how
you know this one character is really
fast and quick and dodge-based more of a
you know kind of like a rogue skirmisher
or something as opposed to this tank
character who deals a lot of damage
there's a valkyrie right there if i'm
not mistaken
it it feels balanced and it feels like
each character has their own
very distinct style and it feels like
every time i go up against one i'm
learning something new every time i'm
nowhere near being a good player in this
game right it'll destroy me it's i have
like a conflict as i've been playing the
campaign or the story mode it's you know
you you know you lock on to a guy and
you do that like just like square off
and uh a couple times i thought i was
actually i don't know i i thought uh i
was in the right mode but it was
actually just ai yeah they put like a
clan
tag on it and we're just thinking like i
know this isn't a uh uh
real person but man that'd be intense
because you just have these situations i
was watching matt play for like two
minutes and he was playing online and
the
teamwork seems real heavy and that's
what's like cool is you know you really
want to like have some team jack going
because he was doing like um
he was up against this one guy another
dude comes in so now it's 2v1 in those
situations you're just you're really on
a retreat you're just all defense so he
just lured these guys into a hallway
and then came out and his buddy was
there one of the other enemies was like
almost done he was clearly trying to get
to him but he was the guy was behind his
other one lured him out and his teammate
just came with the finishers
excuse me yeah there are a lot of great
moments in this oh it was just this
matt played it so right it was just like
that was two minutes of just watching
him it looked really really intense we
have people in this office that play
like street fighter or marvelous capcom
all the time and when obviously it's a
fighting game you can watch and notice
when someone's good as opposed to just
button mashing and this is very much a
fighting game if two people go up
against the other brand new they'll
probably button mash and i think spencer
who's been playing this a lot in our
office says it's one of those games
where you have to really be patient
despite how frenetic it looks and you
have to
take the time defense is huge in this
game which i love uh it's not it looks
like dynasty warriors when you're going
up against creeps uh but when again when
you go up against a hero right here just
out of nowhere i love the feeling of
being like plowing through creeps and
trying to push that front and then all
of a sudden a hero comes over like [ __ ]
this
like a whole different game
um it's becoming more about
which it's funny when you see two people
that know what they're doing going up
against each other because they'll be
switching their guards waiting for the
other attack right so it's like it's
like it reminds me the scene in the
office where dwight and michael and andy
at the end of the the role-playing game
the savannah murder they're just like
it's like a standoff and you're looking
at each other i don't know if it's going
to no nothing to do you're looking like
different poses and it's like an
interpretive dance against each other
uh or like the dude in indiana jones and
uh raiders lost ark who's fleeing his
sword around and he indeed just takes
out his gun and shoots him i wish he
would do that in this game well i mean
i'm seeing some like arrows with like
the samurai right are those like kind of
um
like cool down like abilities you have
yeah pick up abilities you rank up in
campaign uh they're separate than
multiplayer but yeah you get these uh
you can get these flags you plant that
heal people around you or increase
attack you can get these passive
abilities uh mapped to directional sorry
if they're passive you don't need to map
them but you get these passive abilities
they just increase your damage oh
there's one on that you can map to a
directional pad that just refills your
health briefly
and yeah there's it's a it is a deep
game i
i want to play more of it and it is
tough to get into it's a high learning
curve for sure but that was my next
question yes very very high especially
now would be the time to get in i guess
but but then everyone's still learning
right but then matchmaking comes into
play right hopefully it i don't know our
review's not up yet i have to like ask
matt espinella who's reviewing it what
he thinks of the matchmaking and uh and
how they pair you up against other
players of similar experience yeah
because my problem is always like join
in with friends who are who have been
playing longer than i have then i get
into these matches i'm not prepared for
what happened to me in overwatch a ton
yeah it's it's an intimidating game for
sure but it's the fact that like ubisoft
releases and ubisoft has aside from like
the division hasn't had a ton of new ips
i think this is and they're like a lot
of them are military focused or you know
shooters like far cry this is a great
entry so far from what i've played i've
really been enjoying it it's
to be honest it's not something i'm
gonna stick with right now because of so
many other games coming coming out but
it is
pretty creative in some great ways and
obviously this footage is kind of
showing it off but you have these
control points these capture points
there's always something going through
your head like oh that was cool it's
it's one of those things where you see
that there's a hero unit down there
destroying your creeps you're like [ __ ]
should i go try to push that front or
flank around behind them and get this
control point to let us warp uh spawn in
back here
it
is a much more intelligent game than
it's you know bro
testosterone-fueled story mode might
imply and also just like the marketing
might imply
it's a very intelligent game actually
and i really like how the systems play
together and i'm looking forward to
trying to learn a character
that's like that's like the
you know the hero aspect of it right
trying to learn this viking and then
trying to learn this samurai and
figuring out how this night works i'm
looking forward to that aspect if i get
to play more
uh but yeah i guess my recommendation
jump into the story mode first
and
that'll definitely show you the ropes or
if you just want trial by fire jump into
multiplayer you might be way better than
i was just
yeah i definitely want to get through
the single player just to get like a
better understanding of like the three
different classes right like that's what
i'm like more different factions
factions there i forgot how many and
then there were classes they're like i
think there's like three or four classes
within factions correct yes oh yeah so
they'll have like a knight the warden is
a two-handed sword but then they'll also
have one that's faster and speedier
there are certain heroes that are female
specific certain that are male specific
and there's some that you can customize
either way okay um i know like the
valkyrie viking the spear is always
female and she's one of my favorite ones
i love vikings yes uh it is oh yeah so
khalil walker a while back in the
youtube chat i wrote this down he was
asking what our favorite faction is uh
or kelly what would would it be vikings
if you had played i mean i just love
vikings in general because it's my
actual heritage okay
like celtic yeah same here you're rob
what are you
i got some irish in me okay cool all
right a bunch of irish people
i like the samurai in this game they're
my they're my faction of choice are now
the one i'm trying to learn well i'm
also a weeaboo so probably would like
the samurai so just kill all the knights
you see sounds like you you know your
allegiance yeah do you sound really
pissed
i'm
settle this in the castle
what faction even planned uh i actually
picked samurai um
but yeah again like i don't know like i
picked it to play a little multiplayer
and i was like
all i've been playing is the uh you know
the
vanguard yeah crusaders is there some
sort of uh
what's the term
uh asynchronous multiplayer in this game
where like there's this constant war
between the three factions
is that
between different factions right i would
it would be a shame not to do that but
it looked like that same map and i wish
you knew for sure it looked like that
same map also was broken out into like
game modes right as well yeah there's
dominion there's uh
the game modes are escaping me right now
but there are some that are more control
based there are some that are you know
just the one with 1v1 hero mode actually
once you jump into multiplayer after you
play story mode do 1v1 hero mode first
to
figure out how
sorry someone just mentioned syracuse in
the chat apex penguin mike syracuse
ignore it keep going
i don't know if he's in syracuse but
it's weird it's my hometown uh keep
going i'm sorry
1v1 got some
memories came flooding back
syracuse that's a name i haven't heard
in a long time um
1v1 is a good way to get introduced to
multiplayer so then when you see a hero
in the battlefield you're not like how
the [ __ ] do i fight them you're like
okay i did this against this one guy in
that mode now maybe i could do it while
there are creeps all around me and then
potentially one or two more people
coming in because when you start
fighting 1v2 it's so [ __ ] badass to
see someone who knows what they're doing
like if me and my friend are hacking at
this dude and he's blocking both their
attacks you can do that it's like john
wick if he was a samurai right
or keanu reeves if he was a samurai
which is just the plot of 47 ronin or
tom cruise if he was a snake or tom
cruise if he was the last samurai or
seven dudes who were samurai in the
seventh samurai yeah now i get it um do
you see john wick two yet no i wanna
duh i really wanna
learn how to fight off two people at
once and then three
and then like and then like and then an
army yeah
all right and i'm just and i'm
i'm i to be able to dodge bullets
i want to be able to do that move i see
in this game where you like knock
someone's
for an execution you knock someone's leg
down and then you just do the
classic
cutting off of the head yeah
there's this one that doesn't make sense
to me the wardens so if you've killed
someone with a heavy attack okay you
have the choice to do an execution
square or triangle so if you press
square it does this cool one where like
she the warden will just turn around and
like
go up through
the middle of the body right the heavy
one
they'll grab the sword by the blade
stab the hilt into the shoulder and then
pull it
which doesn't make sense to me you have
a weapon you could puncture maybe right
but you also have a weapon that has a
blade on it and you're choosing
you're you're like holding the spoon by
the circular end and trying to eat with
it
see mike it's more badass if you could
cut your hands when attacking it's like
a blood oath yeah this is sounding a lot
like the uh uh kylo ren saber yeah
we'll have some guy will have to make a
video of like here's a hilt with blades
yes we need to see that well it doesn't
make sense to me
the wardens aren't as well trained as
they
talk about
but anyway
for honor is fun uh it's tough
be ready to devote some time to it if
you really want to learn it but i
recommend it uh matt spinelli's review
will be up
sometime soon as he's plowing through
like a lot of it it seems like he's
pretty high ranked by this point seems
like he's pretty good
uh i don't want to play him because i'll
get my ass kicked but
yeah 4runner that is out now on ps4 xbox
one pc
so go check that out let us know what
you think once you play it if you have
played it let us know what you think
callieplaggy on twitter rob handler or
mike mccarty
and that was our last segment for the
day all right okay yeah that's a good
show bye
yeah we uh have to just go through this
giveaway quickly again but as usual uh
next week we'll be talking more about i
think horizon zero dawn we can finally
talk about
i don't even know if i'm supposed to say
that we've been seeing it in the office
and but i kind of just did i guess so
sorry um
next week is what
three day friday a week from friday is
the nintendo switch
no
already yeah march 3rd no what
is that completely wrong no no i'm so
sorry two weeks from friday that's not
the whole embargo for horizon threw me
off don't quote me on that two weeks
from friday is a nintendo switch which
is still crazy still real crazy in two
weeks from a new
zelda game dude
the breath of the wild well you know
what happened to me
oh oh yeah this this it's not this
glaring story of superior i bought i
i bought zelda and then uh over the
weekend was busy and forgot to pre-order
the system itself so now i just have a
copy of zelda so if someone wants to uh
sell me a switch let me know i don't
have anybody wants to buy a copy of
zelda no hell no
i'll get one eventually
but you know people make mistakes it
happens
yeah i mean
does it i deleted pt off my ps4 in
accident let's take
mike
there it is
this is a well-known bit of gamespot
trivia i have not heard this oh
anyways heavy duty
um i want to bring this gravel way up
quick i'll give it to kelly this time
great ooh show it off
oh [ __ ] i just sword hilted you in the
shoulder i'm sorry uh it's a razor black
widow chroma go to gamespot's twitter
account we have uh tweeted out the link
to the story that you can uh
not apply what's the what's the term i'm
looking for you can enter to try to win
uh we have three of these that we're
giving away and they're pretty sweet
it's a mechanical keyboard it's got some
sweet rainbow backlit action so
beautiful um we will be uh later on the
week we have picked a winner once you
enter and uh
yeah oh my god sorry joey's got an extra
switch oh that's awesome what i don't
even have one
neither do i cool that's cool wait so
that's the giveaway um thank you so much
to the people in the back eric hey
richard lee jean-lucky we will uh we
have more footage and content from for
honor halo wars 2
uh pray features will be up they're up
yeah scott wrote something
rob cut a few videos a video a feature
video um i know the uk team did that
walk through a while back if you want to
watch lucy and tamora play and uh
gameplay in general yeah gameplay in
general of all those uh yeah stay tuned
for the forum review halo wars 2 review
next week we have horizon zero dawn
we'll have a lot more to talk about uh
but also as always thanks for joining
and we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
opening